definite date I'd like to think it will
be you know completed within two years
but I can't control what happens in The
Wider economy
thank you very much do we have any
further questions no well counselor
Keithley
oh hi um thank you chair just a slight
follow-up on that
um I'm a bit unfamiliar with the um the
way you Market these properties have you
out established at any particular demand
for any of these plots as it stands on
this particular site in this particular
area yes as part of our consultation
exercise
we received approaches from several
local people and some people who had
relatives outside of Salford priors but
wanted an opportunity like this to
acquire a plot so we've have had local
interests expressed we've also
been speaking with a lady called Sarah
Jane Hart who used to work at John
shepparton has now set up her own agency
in Henley and Arden and she's a a a new
build expert I would say in this market
and she's got a list of people who are
interested as has obviously the
Stratford's own list of people
interested in open custom build products
so you know there is demand out there
for sure
any further questions
no in which case thank you very much
gentlemen
watch me now move on to our final
speaker who's counselor Stanley
welcome counselor you've got five
minutes
um I'll give you a 30 second warning as
well and uh otherwise start when you
like
thank you chair members you have heard
this evening representation from the
parish council and why this application
should be refused I also oppose this
application for the following reasons
I attended as a resident the annual
Parish meeting in April 2022 where the
applicant raised the proposal for their
previous application of 18 self-built
houses it was obvious from the audience
participation that their clearly is not
a public want or need for self-built
houses in Sulfur priors this was
reinforced by an extraordinary meeting
of the parish council in August 2022 and
there also isn't a need for this amended
application of 16 self-built houses
it was also mentioned that the plots
would be sold for six hundred thousand
pounds plus and their target audience
was for young Working Families I fall
into that category and can say so do
many of my friends within the Stratford
District they certain couldn't afford to
buy a plot at this price let alone put
it through the planning stages and then
Bill to completion
very often as a ward member I have
residents asking about more affordable
housing not overly priced plots of land
to build their own home this is not an
affordable way to get onto the property
ladder or to progress
the application sits outside of The
Village's built-up area and will be
being built into open Countryside
meaning it will have an impact on the
local landscape communities and
environmental features being self-built
properties means there is no obvious
time scale for a start and end date
through ongoing construction works for a
time scale deemed impossible to Divine
that will this will have a detrimental
impact on occupiers and users of
existing properties within the area of
which there are many
16 houses could mean a minimum of 32 new
cars on the rural roads of sole
propriers which I would deem the
increases harmful to the local area and
taking into consideration the three new
housing sites in the parish already
there is also an ongoing speeding issue
in this Village along the Evesham Road
where this site will be located this
site sits on a grade two listed
agricultural piece of land this means
that the district would lose a large
area of high quality agricultural land
the planning officer also failed to
highlight the loss of grade 2 listed
agricultural land from the recent
development of prize Crescent which was
once a part of the original boundary
this is not shown correctly in the
report if planning is granted this means
the district will have lost 15.9
hectares of high quality agricultural
land within sulfur prize Parish alone
once this land is gone it's gone
these are the point show that this
application is not in compliance with
as10
as already stated this site sits outside
of the built-up area of the village the
site is almost its site is also not
identified within the Salford 7
neighborhood development plan meaning
that this goes against cs15 and the core
strap of the core strategy and NDP
policy sp6 this application goes against
the s16 sulfur prize parishes classed as
a category 2 service village within the
core strategy meaning they have a 12
share of 700 homes to be built within
the district amongst other two
categories service Villages 12 of 784
houses the planning office of states in
his report as of the 31st of March 2022
sulfur prize is committed or built to
144 homes which equates to 20.6 of the
category 2 lsv total if the 16 dwellings
dwellings proposed as part of the
application were provided this would
amount to 22.9 of the total number of
the category 2 LSB total the above
statement shows that sulfur prize has
almost doubled its percentile
commitments in cs-16 and weight should
be carried here when deciding on this
application today the officer also
stated about having no rigid limit on
the scale of development within an lsv
but surely this is not in the spirit
that the core strategy apology was
originally developed on the officer
lists 48 recommended conditions in his
report should this application be
granted of which for my current
experience at least six could not be
enforced conditions 9 and 40 read
relating to public open space is not
enforceable the parish council had been
battling to get public open space long
School Road and Soulful priors sorted
and it currently looks like an excellent
field for hay condition 12 this is not
enforceable the parish is still waiting
for implementation of traffic calming on
School Road two years after last
occupation
condition 23 is not in the powers of
this Authority or the application
condition 27 we don't have any street
lights here in petition 32 is
unenforceable the planning officer also
States in his report that policies as10
cs15 and cs-16 and NDP policy sp6 are
not consistent with national policy
guidance and legislation this statement
insinuates that it is a developer's
Charter more weight needs to be given to
our current policies they are in place
for a reason to protect this District in
conclusion members you've heard this
evening that there are alternative
material reasons not to Grant planning
permission
thank you
thank you very much councilor Stanley uh
just within your time members do we have
any questions for our war member
catholically
thank you councilor Stanley
um as you are making a presentation I
think I heard you say that you were at
the Parish Council annual or the annual
community meeting of of the parish
and that that you had challenged the the
local need for these houses and you had
had heard none is that what I'd heard
that there was no evidence from that
meeting that there was a local need
because that's in
contrast to what the applicant said when
I asked the same question yes so when
when I attended the April 2020 annual
Parish meeting
um there was there were people there
that were definitely not in favor and I
didn't I don't believe I've heard one
person in support for self-built houses
within silver price
sorry that was when April 2020 sorry
2022 sorry April 2022. okay thank you
thank you very much any other questions
for a world member
no in which case consistently thank you
very much
oh good okay uh we're now moving on to
points of clarification from our
officers members do we have any points
clarification councilor Perry first
thank you chair
um
I did sort of ask about the the plot
numbers in advance of this meeting
um would I be right in thinking that you
can only
um calculate the plot numbers and those
registered based on 31st of October 2022
because at this planning committee we've
had a number of planning applications
for self-built housing that we have
found ourselves granting which would in
would significantly hit the
numbers that are being given in the
report are we bound to go with the
figures because I did hope that you
might be able to come back with an
update on plots granted since the end of
October last year
thank you councilor um firstly the
figures and obviously we had we had an
email correspondence on this point the
figures quoted in Pages 29 of 30 of the
gender pack agenda pack
um are the latest figures that officers
do have to go on I mean answer your
first question of the 31st of October
um that is the latest data that we have
available to us to relate to members
this evening
um
in terms of I don't know if my senior
colleague wishes to offer a view on the
on the make the monitoring of the
Rolling Supply as each committee Goes On
You may wish to offer review it's it's
just that I know having sat on the
planning committee we have been
um there have been a number of
self-billed applications that have been
granted and there have also been
self-built sites that have been turned
over on appeal and it would just fairly
recently
um so it it it I just think it would be
helpful for us as the planning committee
to have a little bit more grasp on the
actual numbers that we're dealing with
because that's very crucial to this
particular application I recognize that
they're you're correct there has been a
number of approvals recently for self
and custom-built housing in the district
um the reason why we rely on an annual
update in this fashion is that of course
by monitoring only the number of
approvals you aren't monitoring both
sides of the equation so the reason we
rely on the 31st of October 2022 is
because at that point the assessment was
made of how many self-built custom-built
houses had been provided how many people
were registered on our list now we know
we've granted more permissions but we
don't know how many people have added
their names to our list during that time
so it would be very difficult for
members to rely on their own
understanding of how many we've granted
without that full picture being provided
if that makes sense
um perhaps through the chair I could ask
um uh councilor Adam to liaise with the
planning portfolio holder to ensure that
we have when we have a self-build
application come before us that we have
an up-to-date list of registered people
because we're controlling that register
and we also have a list of the number of
plots granted I just feel as a planning
committee sorry I'm I'm happy to take
that offline but this is questions for
officers okay thank you very much
yeah I might further out that the number
of self accustomed build houses which we
recognize as having been delivered is
not just simply the number of planning
permissions we've granted you'll be
aware if you've read the um the report
that published statement that what we
look at is the sill forms that are
submitted and until such time as a you
know a
second stage sill form for self-build is
actually submitted to the council we
don't know that that permission is
implemented or that that is secured as a
self-build dwelling in actual fact and
so the advice that we've had through our
legal department and so on is that
relying solely upon permissions or
solely upon the first stage form for
self-build exemption through Sil is not
really adequate we need to look at those
second stage
cell forms and if we do that it needs to
be done in a methodical manner which is
what I rely on an annual statement and
that's the most robust picture that we
have at the current time I'm afraid
thank you very much councilor Harvey
Nick thank you chairman I've got two
questions would you like to me to answer
ask each of them in turn altogether
I'm happy to have them both together
that's fine
um
page 37 of the officers report refers to
this figure of 5.25 in relation to
um
agricultural holding and we've heard
from one of the speakers that another
plot of 13.8 hectares has already been
used the concluding of conclusion of the
the first paragraph on that page is the
site consequently is not deemed to be
significant development in agricultural
land that provokes the question in me if
five percent is insignificant is 10
significant or 15 or where does that
point of significance come in is one leg
to the question and the second leg to
the question is
um of this particular question is are we
entitled to take account of the previous
development which which used in inverted
commas 13.8 hectares of land
did you get my general drift
we do I believe yes thank you cancer
um yes I have the same section of the
agenda pack in front of me um your first
question if I interpret it correctly
what is the the figure of acceptability
for significant or insignificant amount
of land lost
um there isn't a figure
um as such whereby
um an officer can quote and say if it's
above a certain threshold therefore it's
acceptable whether it's not acceptable
for the loss of agricultural land
um each and every application would have
to be considered on its own merits
um different matters of scale and
context have been factored into that
view offered on page 37.
um the percentage figure quoted as is
one that I have provided to you based
for solely on the site being a proximity
2.1 hectares uh of a holding that we've
been told is 40 hectares I've provided
that figure just to give a sort of
contextual figure of the element of loss
and that was the reason why
um it was deemed to not be a significant
development of our cultural land but
clearly that is for members to decide
and and see if you agree with that this
evening the second question you asked
about the and it's been touched upon by
by our speakers this evening the loss of
the the area of Crescent land library of
13.8 hectares
um is that
um you asked is that monitored in terms
of the overall holding
um
my estimation is no my answer to that is
no that's not actually factored into
this assessment
um this application has been submitted
um and assessed against the development
plan that we have available to us at
this time
um and
um the previous permissions
notwithstanding and other parts of the
village have not been factored into that
calculation
but it has quite answered my question
which is are we entitled as a committee
to take that into account in our
deliberation
I think my view would be that you should
determine this application on its own
merits
please
um page 33 is making obtuse now could
the officers confirm that the council's
policy over the the length of the
required marketing period
being reduced from 24 to 12 was due to
the decision of an individual inspector
who determined the application in in the
case of Miller's close welfare is that
is that why we changed the policy
um that's correct yes recent appeal
precedent has dictated that
um the 12-month period has been deemed
to be the commensurate amount of time
for marketing for herself and customer
bill dwelling thank you
thank you very much
um I actually have a question myself
which is uh related to councilor
Harvey's first line of questioning
um with regards to page 36 um in talking
about the agricultural land it also
talks about
um is it demonstrated the poor quality
land is not available
um have you got an Evidence base for
saying that
we have we the local Authority have an
Evidence base in as much as the
applicant has provided technical
information in supports this application
that is inclusive of an agricultural
land classification and other matters of
that nature in the technical documents
provided
um and agricultural justification was
put forward by the applicant
um to to consider the loss of this
parcel of agricultural land officers
read these technical documents and
concurred with its findings and found
this lost to be acceptable in this
instance
thank you very much I believe councilor
Kurt is next
thank you chair
um also slightly following on from
councilor Harvey's first point
um
look at page 37 you're going back to
this agricultural holding can I ask the
Crescent Development
was that part of the same agricultural
holding
do we know
so thank you councilor I might be able
to help here there is a plan provided if
you forgive me for for jumping across
the slides here
um there is
um so on your screens if you can see
that
um that is an app that is the extent of
the holding that was included in the
applicants planning statement so
um the area of orange uh as signified
there is the application site and the
area of red as put forward by the
applicant shows the extent of the act of
the Agricultural holding
um
about 40 hectares and from the visual
that I can see on this screen here as
you can see the Crescent is not included
in the holding on that image as
submitted it's it's not included in the
current application no but my question
is that was that land do we know if that
land in the Crescent was previously part
of this agricultural holding
item in advance to that
um it's been commented on by members of
the speakers this evening that that was
historically part of the holding but
evidence has been submitted in this
planning statement
um dated this updated planning statement
dated in June of this year shows that
present to not be in the holding but if
we take
um
if we give reasonable Credence to the
other statements that it was originally
part of the holding that would mean in
fact there had been an overall loss of
28 of agricultural land in this holding
thank you
so was that a question on that last
point
it was a comment perhaps that should
have been saved for debate chair
I think I would clarify that that isn't
clear and I think I would also clarify
that the holding such as we have before
us is not the entire extent of as best
most versatile agricultural land in the
area as a whole
okay thank you very much do we have any
other points clarification councilor
Keithley
yes thank you chair
um this is a point of clarification in
respect of the um the kind of demand for
these types of houses
um I'm looking at page 43
um where you report that
these schemes are subject to a legal
agreement requiring plots to be offered
to individuals or households that have a
district connection
so so would I be right in saying that
that's a district-wide connection rather
than a more local connection so this is
something for the total District thank
you councilor yes that's correct you're
you're reading of that is is correct
councilor pattingham
um are we allowed to take into account
that the village has already had more
than the number of houses that were
allocated or already built
and and there's the danger of over
development really
thank you councilor um you certainly are
as members and decision makers this
evening
um I I believe I mean at that point
again has been touched on by our by our
speakers this evening I would also say
it's been I would say addressed by
officers in the in the agenda packs
there is an acknowledgment
um that uh the number of houses
committed to Silver prize Again by the
latest data that we have is is of a
certain figure 144 is quoted in your
original packs
um also quoted is is is the minutiae of
policy cs16 which is
um it's a it's not an
um it does not stipulate an upper limit
um so in answer your question yes you
can factor in that element and that
informs your decision this evening
I think in addition to that what I would
add and what members will clearly have
seen from the agenda pack is that the
the development plan the core strategy
and the neighborhood development plan is
effectively silent on matters relating
to self and custom-built housing
and so when we're considering over
provision against policies such as cs15
cs-16 those policies have reduced weight
in the determination of this application
that should be understood because the
date of which the self and custom build
act came in was after those policies so
core strategy couldn't reasonably have
had a policy itself a custom build
but the way the members afford those
policies should be moderated by that
understanding
councilor Parry next
thank you chair
um
appeal a decision on a custom build site
I believe it was in Wellford should we
be minded to give any weight
does that have any implications on the
weight that should be given to all
self-build applications that come before
us
and in particular the one in front of us
at the moment I think it's fair to say
that
um
Appeal casework on self and custom build
houses in this district is coming
forward all the time it's a fairly new
sort of area of planning policy and
because of the situation we're in with
you know the self and customer Housing
Act coming in after our course strategy
and the course strategy not having
policies that directly address it with
very much learning what we can from each
of those appeal decisions as the case
may be and we've had appeal decisions
you know both allowing and dismissing
appeals for self and custom build
housing and it wouldn't you know it
wouldn't be wrong to to take some of the
lessons from any one of those and apply
it in this case to to your understanding
of of how to balance the issues that we
have before us today
thank you a quick one from uh councilor
Curtis next yeah thank you very much
um sorry chair thank you um councilor
Stanley mentioned that a number of these
conditions
aren't actually
within the gift of the the council to
enforce
um could we just have some clarification
on that
our viewers officers is that these
conditions
um are reasonable enforceable they meet
the tests in the nppf I think the
concerns which were perhaps raised is
related to the enforcement of conditions
which members will know is a separate
consideration if an application could be
approved subject to conditions it should
be and the matters relating to
enforcement should be set aside as a
separate issue can I just clarify that I
mean the re to specifically that I've
picked up relocation and speed limit
signage an extension of the existing
strike Street lighting
is that within the gift of the district
council even where we minded to enforce
would we actually be able to enforce
those conditions
so I think what what you have before you
is a proceed of what those conditions
might be and I think in actual fact what
they might entail is that they would in
some way disallow occupation or
commencement of the development or you
know commencement Beyond a certain point
without those things having been
achieved
and so although the applicant would then
be obliged to go to the County Council
to achieve and give effect to the
requirements of those conditions we
could prevent some part of the
development proceeding Beyond a certain
point without that having been achieved
and that is ordinarily described as a
grampian condition that is reasonable
and enforceable
Kurt has raised my question
thank you very much do we have any
further points of clarification no in
which case move on to the debate who
would like to start
counselor Fleming
for my
Parish Council has worked very hard to
produce ndps
and uh
I think that the um
these sort of custom building
inverted common self build developers
almost use this as a back doorway of
getting planning permission if this was
a straightforward development it would
never happen and I think to say now that
you can't give weight to this NDP you
can't give weight to the core strategy
you can't give weight to XYZ
what's the point of these documents
being raised and and and that I find
very difficult and I think what's
happening is that especially as they're
being put into Villages these things it
puts a lot of pressure on people
for their hard work to suddenly be cast
aside because it doesn't really matter
anymore and I think that's very wrong
but that's a personal opinion
thank you Council Fleming um who wants
to go next
I'll start picking on people otherwise
yeah you're very welcome too but I would
quite like debate to involve more than
one counselor councilor Perry next
please
oh come in
um here we go again
here we have another self-build
application in front of us
um
which we can understand and totally
sympathize with the parish council
um and the ward member
um and I'm just trying very hard to find
a material planning reason
that
Rejects
that can refuse this because I just feel
we're over a barrel with the self-built
and custom build Act
that is attracting Developers
the issue we have obviously with this
one self-built you can
put in applications
um and it they're considered favorably
if they're adjacent to the billtop area
boundary this is a site that is already
being put forward in the site allocation
plan
and that goes against you know we have
so we have various things there
um
I'm just looking to my other colleagues
to see if we can find something more
meaningful
um I don't like to see good quality
agricultural land gone but I am
struggling struggling to find
a pertinent material planning reason in
the light of everything else that we've
got in front of us because our core
strategy did not include any policies
that tackled the self-build issue and
the ACT
does carry a huge amount of weight
um so I will wait with interest to hear
from my fellow councilors
thank you councilor Perry councilor
Curtis next
I don't if I can help counselor Perry
here at all
um I mean looking through the report on
page
I mean I wonder if this does come down
it's a it's a very comprehensive report
we do
struggle with these self and custom
build applications however I mean on I
wonder if it is a question of this
committee determining how much weight
we give to existing policies and that
may or may not be in accordance with the
officer's recommendation on page 28
um the officer report says I consider
that policies as10 CS 1516 NDP sp6 are
not out of date and are relevant to the
determination of this application
similarly on page 35
um the report again says I recognize
that the application does not conform to
these same policies
so
I suppose it is it up to the committee
to decide on how much weight
we give to those policies and we may
come to a different decision
if we give that different weight to the
to the officer's recommendation
that is up to the discretion of this
committee I assume
yes it brought broadly speaking that
that is the case yeah yeah um I have to
continue the debate though uh councilor
Harvey next
thank you Jim I find myself in a in a
particular difficulty because I'm going
to speak uh later in this meeting on
another application which involves
self-build
um
Mike my concern is is the weight the
difference between the two applications
this one and the one I will be speaking
about is that this one is for 16 whereas
my the one I'm going to be talking about
is of for much much smaller numbers
however I would point to
a point that was made by councilor
Stanley in relation to CS 16.
and that is the numbers and
in this in in this instance
cr16
calculate uh leads to it has an equation
which leads to a calculation of 84.
um
and counselor Stanley's told us that
this particular award has already had
144 there comes a point
where the words of cs-16 need to be
challenged and I will be challenging
them
the words are no more than around
are the keywords and
it strikes me that 144 is not very close
to 84 at all it's quite significantly
different from from 84. so I am I'm
struggling and I wonder whether in this
particular instance in the circumstances
of this particular application that is a
relevant hook
thank you councilor Harvey I believe
councilor homes next
sorry is that
policies different weights but if the
self and custom build policy over rules
it then are we just opening ourselves
vulnerable to potential appeal and you
know if
oh
so ultimately will it come down to that
and what we say here doesn't necessarily
matter
I certainly don't want it to get the
impression that what we say here doesn't
matter I think this is a good forum for
debate to set precedence as well but I
do take your point
um I I'd like to
um add to the debate as well at this
point I think it's important to note
that well I I do agree with a lot of
what's been said
um and I've I've got a heavy heart on
this type of application as well as many
of us do we I have them in my own Ward
and I've fought them in my award similar
applications
um I think it's important to know when
weighing the balance of uh ca16
particularly the numbers of houses in
any one uh settlement
um I think we do have a right to
challenge them but we need to have
substantive and measurable grounds on
which to challenge them
uh that needs to be for example impact
to infrastructure and that needs to be
backed up by responses from consultees
I'm not convinced that we in this case
have that material evidence to do so my
heart is with you on that when you sort
of talk about weighing these balances
we have to work on an Evidence base
otherwise we will be challenged the
appeal and there is a significant risk
of us losing that appeal
at this point we don't I believe have a
proposal we are going to have to decide
this application regardless of how
uncomfortable it is
can I ask counselors to consider a
proposal of how we go next
okay please thank you
at the last meeting
we uh we brought a very important thing
up that a development was going to be
between two small villages
and it was given a lot of weight because
it would actually of course think
Salford priors
the adjoining Village which not a joint
and it's separate is Abbott Salford
now this
takes Salford priors nearer
to Abbott Salford they're a separate
entity and what this is doing is going
along the Evesham Road which is a link
Road between the two Villages
um and well Abbott self is a hamlet
rather than a village and I just think
that it's one of those things that's
going to completely kill off their
identity I know this hasn't been brought
up in anywhere else but it's something
that we should be considering because
the the map that shows the red outline
of this on on our papers shows the first
building in Abbott Salford not very far
away from this and I think what it's
going to do it it puts a shift on the
next building is the Eastern Arms Pub
well I don't know it's called The
Vineyard now
um but uh yeah I think I think it causes
a problem with
I'm not going to say Urban sprawled in a
hamlet but it's gonna it's causing
problems but it will cause problems by
bringing buildings much nearer to Abbott
Salford from Salford price thank you no
I do I do appreciate that uh councilor
Parry
well in order to get the whole thing
moving
um
I do have a heavy heart about this but
I'm just thinking about solid material
um evidence that would be used in an
appeal situation
um
and therefore it is with regret that I'm
going to propose Grant on this
application
thank you councilor Harry uh I'm gonna
second that for precisely the same
reasons
um
I feel very strongly about this matter
as I know we all do
um
and I think we've all been searching the
um the reports package for for as much
as many reasons as possible but um I'm
afraid we're all found wanting would
anyone else like to speak on this item
before we move to a vote
councilor Keithley
um I would thank you chair
um I think as I've heard around the
table I would agree that this is very
difficult
um to get the balance right you've
commented that we need to look for
substantive material evidence to go
against the officer's report here and
I'm struggling to find that as well
however what I would like to comment on
um perhaps something that we can take
forward is that um
it strikes me that across the district
we have a fairly large number of people
registering
um for self-built plots
um but our our measure of the delivery
of those plots is determined by the
completion now some of these sites can
take an awful long time to come to
completion so the risk is with the way
in which we're measuring this at the
moment
that potentially we're land banking
effectively
um and a large number of plots but
they're taking a long time to come into
the system for us to take account of
them as spots that have been delivered
so I think that's something that we need
to consider going forwards because I
think otherwise we're just facing a
flood of these applications
thank you Council Keithley yeah I do
agree and I think it's incumbent on us
as a local planning authority to keep
appraised of these issues and address
them as as robustly as we can believe
councilor Curtis had something next and
then
a brief question page 27 talking about
the number of developments the number of
dwellings here
um I find I'm troubled by this sentence
I do not consider this would be
unsustainable as there is no rigid limit
I I struggle with the sense behind that
that just because there's no rigid rigid
limit it can't be unsustainable surely
there must be
this isn't really going to make any
difference to the decision of the
committee I don't think but that to me
seems
a very vague sentence that doesn't
really give me any evidence
um just on comment on that I I agree
with the the sentiment of where you're
coming from I think the um the basis
needs to be that there's
it isn't the rigid limit but there needs
to be something solid that we rely on to
go against that that's and that's the
point I made earlier is that there's no
demonstratable impact on on Services
that's
totally unsustainable in principle and
that's why but I do see where you come
from councilor passing him
um yeah I I'm very much in favor of
self-build but I to me there doesn't
seem to be anything that says
that we uh definitely can't reject this
and I think a lot of way taught to be
put
to the work the wishes of the local
people the local Parish Council and the
NDP and the fact that so many houses
have already been built there
um and
Villages like Salford prize need to have
Housing Development that is sort of
organic that is part of the needs of a
local community not not the needs of you
know
um a massive great big area around and
so I'd be in favor of of I'm here again
against approving it
okay thank you um
from Castle Harvey I can very quickly if
possible thank you
um
I recognize the officer's case and why
he's come to his conclusion and I I will
be voting against this I don't want to
propose a motion I'm quite happy to go
with the majority view but I will oppose
this
um on the grounds that I think Council
of Fleming made a good point in terms of
of
he didn't want to use the term Urban
spread urban sprawl but you get my drift
I I think there's a merit in that I'm
conscious that I don't think we've ever
dealt I haven't ever been party to an
application for solar farm where it was
uh the whole thing was at the at the
expense of grade two two agricultural
land this is uh I think that's a a
reason that carries weight and my final
reason is councilor Stanley's numbers
and cs-16 there comes a point for me
where
I weigh that
more heavily than other people seem to
be prepared to do and in and I also need
to be consistent with my the attitude
I'm going to take in in into a
subsequent application and where I'm
going to speak and therefore I am on
balance and I recognize the strength of
the case on balance I'm going to vote to
refuse oh well I will vote against
approval
think thank you councilor Harvey uh
would anyone else like to speak on this
item
no in which case
um The Proposal is to Grant the
application in line with the officer's
recommendations and the update sheet
provided
can I see all those in favor
those opposed
are there any abstentions
in which case it's my vote is the
casting vote and application is approved
uh so this application uh this committee
resolves to approve application
22-02022 o u t
okay
um thank you very much we're now moving
on to item number five which is
application
22-03139 ful land to the south of breach
Lane claverdon
it uh presenting officer is Charlotte
Dix and I believe you're all situated
right okay so uh yeah once she's ready
she'll take it away okay thank you
thank you chair
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle the application site is
located to the west of the village of
claverdon
this slide shows the application site
edged in red it's predominantly an
agricultural field which is within the
West Midlands green belt and the Arden
special landscape area
the dotted green lines that you can see
indicate public rights of way whilst the
red building is breech Farmhouse which
is a grade two listed building noted in
the report
this is a full application for 10 local
needs dwellings consisting of six shared
ownership properties and four social
rent dwellings
in addition a drainage basin landscape
buffers around the site and a local area
of play are proposed
this slide shows the proposed street
scene as viewed from breached Lane
the Viewpoint is shown by the red arrow
on the map you can see the proposed
elevations of plots three to five on the
left hand side of the screen with the
side elevation of plots one on the right
hand side
these slideshows the proposed elevations
facing Northwest from the access Drive
as shown by the arrow you can see plot 8
on the left hand side with the
semi-detached dwellings of plots one two
nine and ten on the right hand side of
the slide
this slide shows the front elevations of
the Bungalows on the southern part of
the site
so the approximate location that the
photo's been taken is again shown by the
arrow on the map
this photo is taken from breech Lane
just beyond the coverton primary school
as you approach the site the access to
the site is just beyond the cars that
you can see on the left hand side of the
screen
you can just see the fencing which is
the edge of the Primary School site with
the three affordable dwellings beyond
that
this photo is taken as you move further
along breech Lane
indicated by the arrow on the map
so we're now facing west so the access
that you can see here would be the
access to the site
the dwellings would be cited beyond the
post and rail fence that you can see
this photo is taken just inside the site
facing Southwest towards the proposed
location of the bungalows
the site again is beyond the post and
rail fence that you can see
so this photo is taken from a similar
location now panning rounds towards the
western boundary and the public right
away which is beyond that
the line of trees that you can see there
would be sized approximately 40 meters
from the western edge of the site
the photo here is taken from breech Lane
sorry
so this is facing the direction as you
can see from the arrow along breech Lane
so the dwellings would be on the left
hand side as you look
this photo shows a view of the western
edge of the site as viewed again from
further up breech Lane
so the site is beyond the fence that you
can see in the photo indicated by the
change in vegetation
this photo is taken from the public
right-of-way looking towards the West
part of the site
you can see the established vegetation
in the foreground so this is a view from
the public right away and the edge of
the site would be approximately 40
meters from where this photo is taken
again you can see the roof of the
existing dwellings in the background
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet and to note that
a member site visit was carried out on
the 18th of July 2023
since yesterday she was drafted a
further objection has been received
which raised no additional
considerations and just to confirm that
officer recommendation is to approve the
application subject to the completion of
a legal agreement
the biodiversity net gain and ecological
issues being sorted and the suggested
notes and conditions on pages 66 and 67
of the agenda along with the three
suggested conditions and nights from the
llfa instead of conditions number eight
and nine on the agenda
thank you chairman thank you very much
Charlotte we'll move on to our first
Speaker then who is councilor Nick
dargan from Cleveland Parish Council
hello councilor you have three minutes
and I'll give you a 30 second warning
otherwise please bring them when you're
ready thank you chair members a brief
summary behind our position of support
for this application
um the primary focus of clavid and Paris
council is for affordable housing to be
made available to a generation of
clavidonians currently excluded by
affordability and availability of
existing stock
our younger parishioners are of the view
that their future living arrangements
sit outside of the village and at the
very least would like the option to
consider otherwise
as a direct consequence of this option
being made available a longer term focus
is for the population of Clarendon
Primary School to be made up of more
children from within the village than is
currently the case
amongst many aspects of the development
that have been discussed in public
meetings over the last few years traffic
flow at school drop-off and pickup times
are always at the Forefront of opinion
shift away from the volume of
non-resident children arriving in and
leaving the village daily would surely
help alleviate this issue albeit
sometime in the future
so in consideration of all the views
presented to Clara from Paris clavid and
Parish Council in conjunction with the
collective view of councilors as perhaps
submission in December 22 we are
supportive of this application subject
to a number of conditions being met
the first one being the s106 to amongst
other things clearly defined the
qualifying criteria for residential
status of each property to the
satisfaction of the parish council
criteria that will remain in perpetuity
on each property any subsequent Clauses
within that agreement that in any way
diminish this stipulation would not be
considered
the second item is the highways audit in
summary the data and the data sets used
for the audit need to be reviewed and
re-run
using more up-to-date tricks data
gathered at more relevant times of the
day and reflective of the appropriate
appropriate traffic flows across the
village thank you
thank you very much well within your
time uh members do we have any questions
for our Parish Council
hello
I think you're free to go then thank you
very much
we'll move on to our next speakers then
who are Francis Hilton and Tony lapic
hello uh you have six minutes between
you
um I'll give you a 30 second warning
again
um otherwise uh how how would you like
to split your time
yeah
who would you like a 30 second morning
for 30 minutes
okay I'll just give you
you would like one yes okay very good
all right take it away um yeah sorry the
button on the right
is that it good okay hello my name is
Francis Hilson and I've been a developer
for over 35 years I'm currently working
for three Charities
um at the moment I'm delivering in
excess of 500 affordable homes for
summer societies most vulnerable
including the elderly those facing
domestic abuse drugs alcoholic addiction
I'm also a resident of plavidan and in
September I will have two small children
attending the school
so I understand the tensions around
planning and I have a personal interest
to ensure my children and those are the
200 or so families are safe as they
travel to and from the school
councilors thank you for visiting the
site yesterday
the road safety audit focuses only on
the development access and does not
consider the risks to Children staff and
families crossing the road and the
significant increase of traffic through
the junction of breech Lane and Langley
Road
I've made two Freedom of Information
requests and I received the information
on 15th of May site visits were done in
the afternoon never in the morning yeah
the morning's the busiest time
the data dates are from 2017 to 2019 put
it another way these are four to six
years out of date
a sample data used is wholly inaccurate
and bears no correlation to the
situation of the primary school and I've
shared this with planning officers chair
and vice chair I hope this has been
shared with a wiser committee last night
please note that of the three samples
that have been used two have large car
parks with excellent drop-off facilities
something which cleverland Primary
School does not have
unless highways officers have since
visited clavidan in the morning and the
afternoon the full assessment referred
to in their letter of the 3rd of July is
seriously questionable and does not
reflect the true status of the highways
and the associated risks
the kid may seem need to 100 certain
that the application has been thoroughly
tested it has not
the planning officer is still asking for
some matters to be approved once the
application
has been approved these include ecology
the flood response is heavily
conditioned there is an outstanding
objection from sdc's waste in recycling
there is no construction management plan
and be mindful there are 200 children at
the school
and the pressurized sewer system owned
by seven trends
Water Authority requires further
detailed Assurance it will not be
affected which actually affects our
sewers
yet the sewer is within three meters of
one of the buildings on the site
as a result of the inaccuracies in the
highways assessment the section 106
there's nothing to mitigate the impacts
the development on the highways and
there is a very serious risk to the
sensitive receptor of the school the
financial contribution is frankly
derisary of only 500 pounds
another way that's two pounds 50 per
child
there was a real fear in the community
that someone and please don't let it be
a child will be injured or were still
killed
therefore the responsibility does not
lie with highways does not respond rely
with the planning officer although they
will be called in that instance it is
with you the planning committee
the community have no little confidence
in the road safety orders and the work
that's been done if nothing else the
applicant application should be refused
on the following grounds related to
health safety and well-being of the
children a genuine fear within the
community the community need the
committee need to be aware there is a
legal precedent and I refer the
committee to the case of the court of
appeal versus Newport Borough Council
versus the Secretary of State for Wales
in
1998. I quote from the Judgment perceive
fear even if not soundly based on
scientific or logical fact are relevant
considerations as they may affect the
amenity of the area therefore they can
amount perhaps rarely to good reason to
the refusal of the planning application
thank you
Toby
I'm speaking on behalf of excuse me I'm
speaking on behalf of Dan Powell who is
the head teacher of Cleveland primary
school I'm reading from his note
uh we are a happy and friendly Community
Primary School located in the village of
claverin surrounded by open Countryside
we have 203 Learners and 210 capacity
between the age of 4 and 11.
as people members have grown over the
years the school has itself grown
following its original build roughly 25
years ago however as the school has
grown the infrastructure around it has
not
highways street parking staff parking
Etc we have 30 members of Staff who need
to park their vehicles around the school
area
I'm speaking to you today as part of our
school Community is extremely worried
sorry our school Community is extremely
worried and fearful that if this
development goes ahead our children
families and school team maybe put at
risk
and this is the increased traffic around
the school site which is clear clearly a
health and safety concern
we're concerned for this during the
construction process but also with the
increased traffic as and when the
development is finally completed
as a school it's not our position to
comment on the rights or wrongs of the
proposed development however the
governing board and I have a duty of
care for our children families and
school team and we urge you to seriously
consider
the safety of our community directly
related to this proposal we urge you to
reject the application to ensure the
safety of our community
I'd like to thank you on behalf of the
head teacher for taking this seriously I
also want to just take my own point that
in Pages 51 to 70 of documentation in
front of you there is absolutely no
reference to the fear or the health and
safety concerns that have been raised
throughout the application process over
the last two to three years and the
committee paperwork is missing on that
there is no requirement for future
inhabitants for the application to be
childbearing age or to our families or
to be proposed parents of children
coming into the school that's your six
minutes after you to wrap up there
thank you very much members do we have
any questions yes Castle Parry first
thank you and good evening to you both
um you may not be able to answer this
um but do you know what the percentage
of pupils actually live in the village
Who currently attend the school the
parish council mentioned that they felt
it was a small proportion
um
sorry can you turn your microphone
please thank you when speaking to Dan
Powell he says there are currently 203
pupils in the school
and he reckons about 150 of those come
from outside the area so approximately
25 come from the village but that
obviously varies on
birth rates and everything else
thank you brief counselor Curtis next
and it was the same question thank you
chair thank you very much councilor
Harvey
um thank you chairman
one of the usual
factors that uh County Highway seems to
take into account when they're
questioned about or proposal is put to
them is
the accident rate
seems a very crude measure to some of us
but I wonder if you could say anything
about the number of accidents or near
misses or anything else which would
illustrate the degree of safety concern
that gives rise to your safety concerns
um well I've lived on Richland now for
seven eight years and there have been
two or three times where I've come down
and a family's been playing and there
have been kids in bicycles both my
children cycle to school
um I have also hit one of the a cat that
belonged to one of the owners of the
three cottages
um Toby over to you I've been living on
Bridge Lane for 21 years
um I think it's true to say as we live
down there we proceed up there
exceedingly quick exceedingly slowly we
are very very cautious of of
um of the constraints of the traffic and
and children
um and that is something that we've
learned to do and and that's right and I
what I can't talk to is actually any
numbers of near misses I don't think
they're registered uh or reported what I
can say is having spoken to the police
in the past to say can we actually get
people not to park outside there there
are yellow chevrons there the police
have said no we can't enforce it uh it's
it's their yellow not white so we we
can't enforce that so there is
absolutely nothing to stop people
parking in the in in the in the lane to
make sure it retains uh
keeping it open
um all I can say is that actually since
our behaviors have all changed with the
delivery of sort of Home Delivery what
you see is that you do see a fast
increase in home delivery vehicles
coming down the lane to the other the
other houses that are down the other
residents
um many of these people are on time
critical drop and pick up as you know
and one can't necessarily speak to their
Affinity with the local
um Road and school pickup time drop-off
time even when the the council has
visited there was a sainsbury delivery
actually I think it was was proceeding
down there at that time so I think
it is congested at the worst times it
could happily convert into something
which is much more formally dangerous
councilor Perry next
thank you chair
um I came on the site visit yesterday
um I didn't notice a lollipop person
does the school have a lollipop person I
live in moreton moral we have
um it's a much smaller school
um similar type of road we actually have
a lollipop man who's there mourning and
afternoon I just wondered whether you
had a lollipop person no there's no
lollipop person occasionally the
Headmaster if he's not being colored by
one of the parents wanders out into the
street with a hive his jacket on
um but there is no sort of if you like
traffic management there are so there
are also no barriers to stop the
children just running off the pavement
and across the road
thank you any further questions
yeah
um I attended a side visit yesterday
um
and wouldn't it be better if the people
who want to stay in the village with
affordable homes and their children go
to the school instead of importing so
many children from outside the area
and also the other thing I noticed I
drove
okay
okay thank you
and answer that question it would be
great if more children from the village
were attending the school but the school
is unbelievably successful and has a
wide draw
so successful schools attract people
you've got amazing staff who do amazing
work
yeah councilor homes
so if hundreds of children are brought
into the village every day for for
school do do do you generally think that
this small scale development is going to
have a much further detrimental impacts
on on the issue of parking and traffic
um
it depends how many
children belong to the 10 houses that
are opposed here and be mindful a school
is earning from five until 11. so
there's a short period of time that the
children will attend
clearly if there are more children
attending from the local community there
will be less cars coming in but we're
talking a few we're not talking 50 75 or
100 different car Journeys we are
talking possibly five or six maximum
thank you any for the questions in which
case thank you very much for your
contribution this evening
right move on to our next speaker who is
Gary Moss
Mr Moss you have three minutes I'll give
you a 30 second warning
I want your uh
situated uh start when you're ready
thanks
thank you chairman and
I want to thank the officer first of all
for producing an excellent report
um she will know this has been going on
for some two years this is the second
application uh numerous amendments
changes to ensure we get the right
scheme in the right place we feel
strongly and more actual housing my um
clients who are you know have known well
provided affordable housing throughout
the district feel this is the best
available site it's actually the only
site that's come forward in terms of
call for sites and therefore we are
restricted to what we have on site and
the officers report covers most of the
points so all I want to do is sort of
clarify and give a bit more background
to the concerns which we fully
understand I have school-aged children I
can fully understand the concerns from
the residents traffic around schools is
a problem pretty much everywhere we have
however just in terms of the road safety
audit
yes it was based on qualifying data from
a sample sites but this is common
practice for All Transport assessments
it should be noted that that's all that
it was actually done for the 12 unit
scheme this is now only 10 units
secondly the data or be it dated back to
2017-18 was pre-covered which meant
traffic generation movements were far
higher than they are now where people
are working from home and the situation
has changed
more importantly the road safety audit
specifically looked at the access but
also the wider area and spoke directly
with the head teacher regarding their
concerns about the school
um clearly there is two-thirds or 25
from the village that is a lot of cars
coming in we will not change that
situation in the short term hopefully
longer term that number will reduce as
we're providing affordable homes for
people in clavidon where they can
clearly walk to the school
there is a construction management plan
attached to the road safety audit and
transport statement and again that can
be developed and is specifically derived
to avoid all the usual issues around
school drop-off pickup time
um some other points I'd just like to
clarify as well the transport statement
that was submitted there has been no
reported accidents in clavid and there
was a very minor accident on the
junction but that's the only recorded
accidents for uh the village
would also suggest that in terms of
traffic one of the key things about
trips data is that it's based on early
morning trips School runs that won't
apply for our development because
hopefully those will be going to the
local school overall we feel there are
no technical objections and no reasons
to withhold support as per your officer
support thank you
thank you very much just within time
members do we have any questions
counselor Keithley
thank you chairman uh thanks very much
for the uh that explanation
um at the end you mentioned uh trip data
can you tell us I mean we've heard
there's already a lot of traffic in that
area homes aren't built yet
um can you tell us how many additional
vehicle movements there would be in a
day from these 10 homes do you do you
have that information I don't think I
can see that here
thank you
right so according to the table within
the transport statement and again this
is for 12 units not 10 as now proposed
there would be
um
a traffic generation in total of 54
daily movements that's 26 arrivals 28
departures
presumably that's throughout the day
that's the daily
um being so at the peak hour so eight
till nine yeah it's generated two
arrivals five departures or seven in
total and the time period of five to six
o'clock there is four arrivals two
departures resulting in a total of six
so it's a car every 20 minutes or
something yeah thank you
any further questions
no don't believe so in which case thanks
very much for your contribution this
evening
right uh we now move on to our last
speaker who is councilor Parker
good evening councilor uh you've got
five minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning uh otherwise start when you're
ready
um yeah thank you um uh chair and
counselors
um I'm speaking today
uh as a man very tweaked by this
application uh I've been to view the
site three times and uh you know I've
taken great kicks it's in Greenbelt and
we need to take take care I would like
to thank the rural housing enabler and
the uh Warwickshire Rural Housing
Association for the work they've done
bringing this forward I think they've
done a great job and for me uh the need
and the size of this development has
been established so uh I think that that
that's a great job and I think also uh
the paying officer needs credit for the
work that she's done too
uh the location will always cause some
upset uh wherever it goes it will reduce
the openness of one environment or
another
but actually this is a A Tale of Two
professionals on the one hand we've got
highways the professional body looking
at the junction on the other we have
the head teacher who we've heard about
Mr Powell
um
he has uh a duty of care an owner as
tutor of care frankly not something I I
would like to have on my shoulders
of making sure that the children uh come
in and leave school in in a safe way and
uh uh clearly uh he spends quite a lot
of his time outside in his high Vis on
the road trying to make that happen
and I I speaking to to Mr Powell and and
viewing the site have this
um uh conundrum that as long as we are
expecting him to carry out his duties
appropriately
we as parents and as a society as a
community should support him in return
and clearly something has broken down
that is not happening he feels
unsupported and uh as long as he is
feeling unsupported in carrying out this
important function I cannot support this
this application does not mean I do not
want to see it happen does not mean that
um uh it isn't probably the right
development in the right place in in due
course but something needs to happen
because there's been a breakdown of the
process and fortunately when there's
been a breakdown the process we have
this magnificent body here in front of
me who are able to uh resolve that
process problem
with this system that we have and I hope
that you will find a way of resolving
the the conundrum of the two
professionals being at loggerheads
something is wrong when one professional
is saying it's fine and the other is
saying it's really not fine
thank you very much any questions
thank you very much councilor well
within your time members do we have any
questions counselor Perry first
thank you and good evening councilor
Parker
um would you agree then that there is an
existing problem at school with the
collection and the drop-off
of parents
um we understand 75 are coming from
outside of clapperden so there is an IT
the conundrum is there is already an
existing problem there
um and it would be I mentioned to the
other speakers do you think in your
viewer lollipop person would help
overcome this issue there is an existing
problem
uh uh councilor Perry I mean I think
you've hit the nail on the head the the
problem already exists which is part of
kind of the pain that I feel that
someone has come forward or a body has
come forward with uh what would
ordinarily be a development which I
would love to support uh for all the
reasons
um that you've heard from the parish
council you know uh kind of 100
and and
um but the situation we have is you know
the school has been expanded nothing has
been done then there's been a
development as those who visited saw
yesterday built
um uh close to the school uh and that
that was a subject of pain uh for the
head teacher and and he had to fight and
fight and fight to get any assistance
with infrastructure like a footpath and
and and stuff like that and and somehow
we've got everything back to front uh
and and uh
uh and I think as you've established the
problem pre-existed
any further questions remembers
no in which case Council Parker thank
you very much for your contribution this
evening think of your time
all right so we now move on to points of
clarification from our officers
um I'll remind you at this point that we
have Steve Harrison from Warwickshire
County Council highways um with us for
any clarification on those
um items uh also apply a reminder to
make sure we all speak into our
microphones when when we do uh do we
have any points of clarification
councilor Curtis
thank you
um two things really if I know
um page 57 looking at the provision for
parking
um just to clarify the parking
Arrangements on this new development do
meet our policies don't they I think
Charlotte
is that correct the parking requirement
does meet the SPD policy and just
picking up from the parish council
um
mcdargan
um I believe he was saying that
the section 106 which should contain a
provision
that
um that would enable
the parish council
being in control of the sort of
residential criteria in perpetuity I I
probably got not quite got that right
but that seemed to be the gist of what
he was saying is that something that the
district council can put could agree to
in a section 106.
it's not something that we would
ordinarily think is reasonable or
necessary to make the planning
application acceptable
thank you that's alive
councilor Harvey next
German
um I think it was Mr Hilton who
mentioned the case that an appeal court
case of Newport Borough Council 1998 I
didn't quite catch the whole reference
um were you aware of it is it relevant
um should we know more about it
uh so this is to do with the perceived
levels of fear
um so
fears and concerns that held by members
of the public could be a material
consideration if they either relate to a
matter which is a material consideration
such as Public Safety or they're
objectively Justified and this can be
demonstrated through ways such as
history of issues regarding the road
so members
um as the decision makers could give
weight to the perceived levels of fear
if you feel that the acceptability of
the risk is such that
um that there is a perceived level of
fear in this case
supplementary
um
were you aware of this case when you
wrote your report and does your report
reflect the importance that we should
attach to that particular case
yes I was aware of this case when the
report was written and
um in terms of the assessment that I
made as a case officer it is something I
took into account
but because we have no objections raised
from County highways and they are the
um
the consulties in this matter and the
expert in terms of Highway Safety
um it is not something that I consider
to outweigh the benefits of the scheme
in this case
if I could ask him County Council Steve
Harrison to to answer that oh yeah I'm
happy to have a collaboration okay thank
you just to add to that in terms of in
terms of the recorded accidents in the
vicinity of the of breach Lane the
school
uh look back to the to 1990 there's been
one slight accident in 2003 which is
about 75 meters south of the junction
between Langley Road and Bridge Lane on
Langley Road and that was caused by a
driver error there's been no accident
recorded personal injury accidents at
all over the last five year period and
took one in the last uh 30 two years
thanks Chad um
we've heard about the um the sort of
Fairly what I'd I'd consider a fairly
small incremental increase in the amount
of traffic movements up and down the
lane as a result of these 10 properties
but people were parking when we went to
the site visit people were parking on
the the sort of the yellow hatchings and
what I want to understand is why why
can't parking restrictions be enforced
in the location like that would you be
able to answer that
but it
it seems the um just a
Jonas head slightly is that you wouldn't
expect it's given that the parking on
the site meets uh SPD standards for a
development of that size you wouldn't
expect parking
um generated by this development to be
over spilled onto the public Highway
so that's that's one issue
um in terms of the parking
um uh on inappropriately outside the
school if it provides a safety issue
then that can be reported um to the to
the police it can be deported to the
highway Authority
as far as I understand
um although we don't have that
information in front of me
um I have no record of that causing a
problem and there's certainly no records
in uh recorded accidents without
actually causing a serious issue along
breach Lane
that can be substantive substantiated
David
I would like to just add something I
think it's just important for members to
focus on the application that we have in
front of us
um it's not necessary for this
application to remedy all ills it
effectively needs to only mitigate the
impacts of itself
and consume its own smoke if you like
I do have one more question and that is
um when we went to the site visit we
could see that the the the school hadn't
got safety railings in fact children
could walk straight out onto the road so
I guess with this application if there
is an increase in vehicle movements then
this perceived fear about the vehicles
coming from this development the
additional Vehicles come into the this
from this development could cause
um people to be more concerned about the
safety of their children however what I
would say is
um you've noted on page 65 that under
the section 106
there is
um 500 pounds for road safety
could you tell me whether or not this is
determined by uh you or the applicant
has put this forward towards this figure
of 500 pounds come from
uh this is based on a figure of 50
pounds per dwelling that's proposed
that's how the 500 pounds has been
reached and that's the standard figure
that we would use across the district
for in terms of road safety initiatives
thank you for that I would draw also the
attention to almost 125 000 pounds of
community infrastructure Levy arising
from this development
could you confirm that the schools are
allowed to apply for Community
infrastructure Levy for improvements
just to know if I can draw your
attention to the update sheets say
that's just to confirm that
um that figure that in the report would
only be a contribution if the scheme did
not come forward and wasn't secured as
affordable housing and local needs
dwellings so as this has been put
forward as affordable housing it
wouldn't need to pay those silk
contributions
um as it should be secured in terms of
the legal agreement as affordable
housing so there wouldn't be any seal
contributions in that fight
one follow-up to that um one point
catholically did rage was are Schools
allowed to apply for sill monies for
infrastructure are you aware
I couldn't say with certainty but I
imagine so certainly I imagine the
parish council could
thank you are there any further points
of clarification councilor passing them
there's a hundred pounds in for
sustainable travel can I ask what that's
for it doesn't seem very much
again that's a standard figure in terms
of 10 pounds per dwelling that's
proposed and would be sought and secured
as part of the the legal agreement
yeah I think in terms that's more of a
welcome pack in terms of the um the
dwellings once they're um they're built
huh
still right sorry
um so would it be possible to have a a
transport management sort of plan to
allay the headmaster's fears about this
in terms of sort of the cars parking
further away and and speed limits and
things like that that might make the
Headmaster
um be more favorable to this development
it's not something that's considered
reasonable or necessary to make the
development acceptable in this regard
we've got no objections from County
highways and there weren't any concerns
raised in that manner so it's not
something that we would recommend in in
this case
thank you um are there any further
points of clarification very quickly
Council Keithley one we heard that there
was no construction management plan is
that is that the case
there's a construction management plan
condition which is one of suggested
condition number four so that that would
be um dealt with
um prior to development commencing on
the site
okay thank you
lovely um I don't believe there are any
further points of clarification in which
case we're moving on to the debate who'd
let counselor Perry
thank you chair
um found the site visit particularly
helpful
um and it was helpful to see
um what I would describe as an existing
issue in terms of traffic and parking
um it's always very welcome to see a
parish council come forward in support
of affordable housing and I think it was
highlighted in particular where we've
only got 25
of local children going to the school
is is a lovely Village an area but it is
traditionally an upmarket facility where
I can totally understand that
um younger people living wanting to stay
in the village would find it extremely
difficult particularly in the current
situation and even trying to find
affordable rental accommodation so I'm
very happy to propose
Grant of this application I think it's a
very much it's a very well thought out
scheme it has been carefully managed
appreciate is in Greenbelt but there is
that is overcome by the local need
measures which is then allowable as far
as green belt policy so I'm very happy
to propose grant for this application
chair thank you very much Council Murray
I believe councilor Curtis was next yes
I would be very happy to Second Council
Paris proposal
thank you uh councilman Serafin thank
you chair councilor Curtis beat me to a
second in that one
um I'm all in favor of local housing
need and I was pleased to hear from the
parish council and
I did attend a side visit and I did
actually drive down when the children
were coming out of school very slowly
and I would probably recommend to the
school that they put up railings outside
to stop them running out into the road
and possibly they have a safety person
when school children leave like they
used to do in my day long time ago so I
will be supporting this application
thank you thank you counselor and serif
and would anyone else like to speak on
this item Catholic equally yeah thank
you chair I think it's a well put
together a proposal I am
I Echo the thoughts of councilor Parry
that in a in an environment like
clavidan would really like to encourage
local people that have grown up there to
be able to stay there at the moment that
must be extremely difficult because the
cost of housing I I do get the the point
that um councilor Parker made about the
duty of care that the teacher has to the
children and the difficulties that he
feels in the pickup and drop-off time
but I I do feel that's um an existing
issue and I think the incremental
increase to traffic movements from this
development are very very small
um relatively small shall I say
um but I do feel that the school my wife
used to work at school and um I know
that they had lots of problems crossing
the road they had people helping they
even gave the kids badges to encourage
them to walk further rather than walk 10
yards to the parents car I think there
are things the school can do and this
certainly can apply for funding as well
one thing I would like to add is that
coming from a construction background I
remember
conditions of
um of heavy Goods Vehicles delivering
and taking material away from site at
certain times of the day and I think
that's very very important we we had um
I can remember slovenbargoes on
deliveries and vehicle movements at
times when there were children around
the school I wouldn't want to see that
written into a construction management
plan specifically because there'll be a
lot of heavy Goods Vehicles movements to
and from but I'm very happy to support
this application
thank you councilor yes I believe that
there is a concern that can be addressed
through a construction management plan
um and I'm I'm happy to uh to go along
with the The View that that seems to
have been expressed so far I think
affordable housing is an incredibly
important thing for our district to
provide uh this does look to be a full
an appropriate scheme I do appreciate
whether members of the community are
coming from I'm you know I want them to
feel that we have listened to to what
they've said um I think there are
existing problems though that it is not
within our gift to um address in this
place right now and I certainly
encourage the um our you know our fellow
authorities to to assist in them with
that
um if nobody else has anything further
to add we can now move to the vote The
Proposal is to Grant uh in line with the
officer's recommendation and the updates
in the update sheet
subject to the concerns relating to
ecology and public open space being
overcome
and that redelegated to officers can I
see all those in favor
in which case committee resolves to
approve application
22-03139 ful thank you very much
okay uh members
um we're actually going to have a slight
reorganization of the agenda
um
and I'll explain uh that uh now uh
application uh under item nine which is
application
22-02564 slash ful dasit Field House
asset Road avond asset
um has been referred to committee but
um is also to be is actually to be
decided by the planning inspectorate and
so
um the council requires a committee to
make a determination on that to make him
make the case to the planning
inspectorate there is a statutory time
scale associated with that
um and so given the time time of the
running of this meeting it seems prudent
at this point to move it forward to make
sure we're not at risk of not hearing
that item tonight I appreciate that
that's a bit of a thing to address but
as a result I'm going to move item 9
forwards
um following that we'll go back to the
agenda as planned
in which case we are looking at item
number nine which is application 22
02564 slash
it Field House Avon uh sorry dassey Road
avondacit
um we only have one Ridge oh sorry oh um
I'll let the uh
sorry you're ready
yeah sorry uh
um please get get situated and plugged
in then we can go ahead with a
presentation for that item thank you
thank you chair
um this application uh relates to uh
does it feels House in Avon dasset and
as the chair has referred to um it has
been brought before members this evening
uh due to a non-determination appeal so
members are here this evening not to
determine the application only to put
forward a recommendation which will then
be brought forward to the inspectorate
and they will be determining the
application
members were too minded to Grant the
obligation
um we could also then put forward draft
conditions which we could then attach to
the inspectorate however it's likely the
appeal will then be withdrawn
okay so that's the context uh the
application site is identified by the
black dots on the map and is located
within open Farm sorry open Countryside
setting approximately a kilometer east
of avondasset and 800 meters west of
farnborough Village
full planning permission is sought for
the construction of an indoor riding
arena this would be positioned within
the Northwestern corner of the site
which operates as an established equine
business the site is identified by the
red line here
foreign
house
which is located here which is a gray
two star listed building the walls
attached to The Farmhouse are also going
to listed and The Farmhouse is two
Pavilion buildings which are located uh
symmetrically either side of The
Farmhouse are also gray two listed in
their own right
farnborough Hall lies
to the southeast of the site and is also
a grade one listed building together
with its Associated outbuildings which
are grade two and also is located within
the grounds of the grade one listed
registered parking Garden which is all
the dotted red area here known as
farnborough Park
uh farnborough Conservation Area is
identified by the pink lines on the plan
which is less than 500 meters to the
southeast of the site and
also there's the sourland pool local
Wildlife site which is identified by the
turquoise lines on the plan which is
located less than 300 meters East
the site also lies within the felden
special landscape area
this is an aerial view of the site just
to give you some context so the area of
development lies within this Zone here
this aerial photograph is a little
outdated because there has been
subsequent development of a stable
building which you'll see in a moment
together with some turnout areas Fortune
at areas for the horses but this is the
uh the Farber Hall these are the
registered parking Garden
turning now to the proposal so as I just
mentioned originally an application came
forward for these stables and the
um indoor riding arena the application
was then separated out and this stable
buildings as you'll see very shortly has
been constructed we are left now with
the outstanding indoor arena
uh so the proposals
um uh include the in planting of
additional
um trees
um to the east of the um uh indoor arena
together with some new Hedgerow planting
along these areas here
the
sorry I think
apologies I seem to have lost one of my
slides
um the proposals sorry the arena would
have a depth of 40 meters and have a
width of 20 meters with a maximum Ridge
height of 7.7 meters
um when on an ease height of 4.8 meters
it would be constructed using a steel
portal frame with horizontal Timber
boarding
and with elements of brickwork which you
can see in this area here and also areas
of transparent paneling the roof would
be
um would be constructed with a brown
cement fiber boarded roof
foreign
this is a aerial photograph zoomed in
slightly so the area again is is this
area here this is does it feels house
and the two Pavilion buildings either
side
this is a view of the site so as you can
see it's got an existing Menage area
ineffectively would be constructed
within this Zone you can see there's the
levels difference here which was shown
on the previous
um plan
um
and this is The Stables which has
already been constructed so proposing a
new Hedgerow along this area here
and this is the view of the southern
part of the site
panning around now
um
this is effectively a composite view the
southern boundary where you've got these
Menage area
of a breakout area there
and then looking towards does it feels
house itself
and another manage which you'll see
in a moment so this is the other Menage
area and this is looking back down the
driveway
um the application area is
to the right
and then this is does it feels house
with the Pavilion buildings
this is looking back towards where the
application
building the arena building would be
situated
against the backdrop of these existing
trees
again just showing it in in relation to
the existing Stables
and then this is a view looking
from the access driveway down towards
farnborough Hall and farnborough park
which I say is both grade one listed
um
and then this is a view from dasset road
which is from the highest point in the
road and the application
um site would be towards the right of
these buildings
there are no updates to report and the
recommendation is to refuse planning
permission for the two reasons set out
in the committee report
thank you very much uh our speakers on
this item are Mark dudes and Kate Rocha
hello
um if this like takes seats there
um
yeah that's fine
um so you'll have three minutes between
you uh if you could speak into the
microphones and press the button on the
right the red light should come on uh
how would you like to split your time
yeah absolutely fine
um
lovely thank you I'll give you a 30
second warning before your time is up
otherwise uh start when ready thanks
oh yeah that's it
I start
um I'd like to thank the councilors for
their time today and also the parish and
their parishioners for their continued
support
tonight we seek counselor support in
overturning the refusal recommendation
to allow us to withdraw the appeal if
you're minded to refuse tonight I ask
you to defer your decision to the next
meetings the have the opportunity to
visit the site
there's a bit of background the
beautiful does it feel to do my home
since 2004 and I've slowly been
developing my business to asset Eventing
since 2007. along with my long-standing
team we produce top-class three-day
event horses which we sell worldwide and
I'm really proud to say this is up to
Olympic level
our competitive season runs march to
October so most of our clients buy from
us November to January we have really
struggled to stay competitive in the
marketplace when we become unreliable
and cancel clients due to bad weather
it's not great when you've traveled to
America
we're finding all our competitive events
have in competitors have indoor Arenas
and we are at a disadvantage without one
I'd like to add how much should we
support the local community to the value
of over 250 000 pounds annually in
employment and also in local suppliers
in reference the objections raised I'm
not sure any Consultants have made of
site visits but despite how the reports
reads we do have a common goal and we
have no interest in ruining the way our
wonderful and historic family home is
appreciated
in response to the committee report he
International trust refer to concerns
over the site this is actually the site
to form a case officer recommended us to
develop we've already reduced the height
of the roof and the arena size is the
recognized minimum industry standard
size
the barn is over 100 meters from the
house and we plan to sync it down as
you've seen to minimize any attraction
from the house the eaves of the barn
would come to just above ground floor
level
we're very happy to discuss making or
make concessions on materials open sides
but we felt Timber was the best option
the conservation officer has concerns
over symmetry apart from The Farmhouse
Pavilions in the old Stables none of the
existing or surrounding buildings are
symmetrical as you can see on the site
map
there's no impact I believe no impact
from farnborough Hall as you just can't
see the site from there there's
extensive tree coverage and a number of
hills in the way
regarding screening we can go into more
detail with more time but the only
on-screen side would be the front side
which we have plans to plant once the
building was developed the case
officer's report is on one hand seems to
be quick to identify alleged harm but
quite slow to identify how incredibly
hard to discern the building would be
from any public vantage point and slow
to accept the benefits the arena will
bring to my business
oh
um I feel this building would not
dominate the landscape nor would it
compete with and detract from the
historic Farmstead and its setting as
quoted given by above description I find
it hard to see how these statements can
be accepted we choose this house as our
home because of its historic nature when
our inherent asset Fields I have I need
to have a sustainable business off the
land in order to stay here all of our
all of our developments are aimed at
achieving this goal to enhance the
property
the officer appears to make concessions
on his to his View
okay um
members do we have any questions for our
applicant or their agent
Castle flowing
you you're saying that the the building
set down I see from the side map it
what's the height
taken into consideration how low you're
setting it down it was seven and a half
meters to the Apex wasn't it you were
saying so how does it that stack up
against what can be seen from the side
so can you turn your microphone on
please
from if you were to stand
where the buildings are and you look
across
a crop
members any further questions Council
Harvey
thank you chairman can I put to you a
specific and sort of poke at you and you
could respond however you want in a
letter from historic England on the 6th
of December last year the letter
included the following a large building
in this location will have a potentially
serious impact on the significance of
The Farmhouse and Associated Pavilions
we've got as a committee we've got
evidence from
the conservation officer from historic
England and from National Trust which
seems to substantiate or support that
that sort of a statement and on the
other hand we have to consider what the
public benefit might be that might
offset that harm could you tell us what
do you think the public benefit of The
Proposal might be please
so the that question is predicated on
there being one of the two levels of
harm set out in the framework the first
one is a paragraph 202 which talks about
a less than substantial degree of harm
which then must be weighed against
public benefits and then there's another
level of harm which we're nowhere near
but is called substantial harm that's
basically demolition of listed buildings
it's our position and and we've written
quite a lengthy Heritage assessment that
their the level of harm it doesn't meet
that less than substantial harm
therefore we don't need to weigh public
benefits there are still public benefits
arising but we simply don't need to
reach that threshold and on that point
also on the Heritage England response
the the thrust of their objection was
the the lack of a Heritage assessment
which we have undertaken around a
25-page document to go through the
significance of the building its asset
and the impact that that harm could
potentially have on the setting of that
building and that's been the result of a
lot of professional inputs so I hope
that officers obviously it's available
online but hope the counselors have read
that document I hope that answers your
question
thank you councilor Perry next
thank you and good evening can you
advise
um what if any further jobs would be
created as a result of having a covered
indoor arena such as what is proposed in
front of us today
uh yes what we would be looking to
employ one more person
thank you any further questions no in
which case thank you very much for your
time this evening
oh no you can you can go back to your
sees now thank you
um so we don't have any other registered
speakers for this item which means we
can now go to points of clarification
for our officers members do we have any
points of clarification
Harvey
in view of the agents uh answer to my
question are you moved in any sense
would you want to can is there anything
more you can help us to understand the
importance of what he said to us
no I think all the elements are covered
in the report in terms of how we
perceive the harm and we have very
clearly weighed up the benefits that
have been put forward but we just don't
consider that that would outweigh the
lesson substantial harm being arising
Castleberry thank you chair
um you mentioned beforehand
um Louise about the time scale of this
particular application before us
um
would we have would there be sufficient
time scale if we were to defer for a
site visit would that
um
would we have the time to have a site
visit and for this to come come back
so that is not an option regrettably I
think not
any further points of clarification
know in which case we can move to debate
who'd like to start
anyone
I'll pick on you
we've had two speakers so far and it
always ends up being Anne who starts it
um I'll pick on councilor Harvey
Short Straw
um
I'm very conscious from my own
background if I'm having worked
for my living set in a business that was
within a grade one listed building
within a grade two star Gardens uh how
rare these these assets are
um
I find it very difficult that we've got
three
um
sources of of opinion who are steeped in
assessing the
architectural and and Heritage Integrity
of a proposal and when all three sound
the same sort of notes I find it
difficult to to disagree with the the
officer's recommendation
um so I am
proposed that we accept the officer's
recommendation to refuse
a counselor Perry
thank you councilor Harvey my big
concern about this
um
a I think it would have been very
helpful if we'd been able to go and have
a look at the actual site my big concern
is actually the scale of the proposed
development I appreciate for this type
and nature of indoor arena it needs to
be that size but you know we it it is in
the region of of sort of just over 25
feet high you know 40 meters I mean it
is it's not as small
um building and whilst I am someone that
is very positive towards
Economic Development particularly in
rural locations
which and I've looked at as10 I've
looked at cs22 but unfortunately I I
feel that it is just too big in terms of
its scale and it's not as though there's
it's replacing an existing building and
having an extension onto that this is
totally in open Countryside and
therefore
looking at the core strategy it doesn't
fit with as10 or cs22 but I just would
have liked to have gone and had an
official site visit and I think it's
unfortunate that we haven't got that
opportunity but I'm happy happy to
Second councilor Harvey's proposal
thank you councilor Perry uh yes I
[Music]
um
councilman I'd like to
um I tend to agree with what some of the
other officers the other members are
saying but having spent
you know every other weekend for the
last 40 years in and out of window
schools like this
this is a tool of their trade it's
if they want to work 24 7
every week of the year they can't
produce the type of animals they're
trying to produce without this facility
and okay it's going to create a bit of
extra
um
extra employment as well but having sort
of worked owned and known people I mean
used to run a big riding school some
years ago
um it's an essential tool of their trade
and uh so whilst I'm not sure how I
would
how would support it in terms of what
other people are saying I the 40 40
meters by 20 is the minimum size that
you can ever build these things that
that that's exactly it
um so I'm not sure how I would argue
against what the other people are saying
just at the moment but
um I won't be I won't be voting for to
to support the officer's recommendation
thank you very much any further
contributions councilor homes yeah I I I
also have to Echo what what cancer
Fleming is saying I think they've made a
significant effort to to sink into the
ground it's a hundred meters away from
from home
um and I think that they're being
negatively impacted as a business by not
having this facility and so yeah I'll
also be going along with Council Fleming
all right thank you um
I mean from from my part in the debate
I'm more inclined to agree with
counselors
um Harvey and Parry I think
ultimately I I do appreciate the
um aspect of the the business
um I do appreciate the the fact that
this is a typical Arrangement that some
businesses of this in this area have
however the assessments made by three
incredibly
um well substantiated organizations to
the Heritage impact
um way incredibly heavy uh in the
officers report and in my mind as a
result
um
ultimately it's
incumbent on us as a local planning
authority to ensure that these
assets are maintained in perpetuity
and I do have concerns as per the
officers report that
um
this would would have a detriment to
them so I would be going
along with the officer's recommendation
um are there any other members who wish
to speak on this item
know in which case oh sorry Council
Curtis sorry
um do we know that historic England and
the National Trust have actually made
site visits
uh I can't confirm that
um in terms of the individuals who
responded to this application no
because yes I I feel
given what we've seen of the site and
the
um if it's made to reduce the the site
level the distance or the the roof
levels the distance from the listed
buildings and from some of the photos of
the screening that is it's not visible
from the road I
I would feel happier
knowing whether or not it's talking The
National Trust have actually made the
site visit because I think it's quite
clear from some of the photos that we've
seen
that
you could come to some conclusions that
may be different if you and as cancer
Progressive it's regrettable that we
can't have a site visit before but
without knowing that there actually have
been a site visit by those two
organizations
I am less inclined to give their
evidence as much weight as I may have
done otherwise
foreign
I appreciate that line of thought and uh
I certainly sympathize I think we all
you know a number of applications come
before us where we do have concerns that
site visits haven't been uh forthcoming
from our consultes that being said they
are still the statutory consultees who
have provided very detailed and
collaborative report
um reports that substantiate each other
I don't I have no evidence to a country
myself
nor am I a an expert on this aspect of
planning which why I rely on Experts
reports
um
that being said I appreciate also that
we would like a site visit however that
is also not not an option for us as we
are not there The Authority who will be
determining this application
so I although I do appreciate your
concerns I don't think that's something
that we can really hold a significant
weight in this setting at this time
on our SS are there any further comments
anyone would like to make
okay in which case we've had a proposal
and a seconder for uh refusing the
application in line with the officer's
recommendations are there any updates
uh so in line with the officer's
recommendations
can I see all those in favor
all those opposed
any options no don't believe so in case
committee resolves
to defend the appeal
in line with the officer's
recommendations
thank you very much
um we've been going for almost two and a
half hours I'm going to suggest a quick
Comfort break of no more than five
minutes after which we will
uh members um we're gonna
restart the the meeting where we left
off
um based on the time uh and the
Constitution we're not able to uh
continue the meeting Beyond three hours
without a vote
um we are about to start item
six
and we would then have two further
applications to here after that
we have we're still running we will have
to hear this next item so we need to
essentially decide whether we are going
to hear just this next item and then
adjourn the other two items to a future
meeting or continue through to hear the
whole agenda this evening
I'm happy to have a very very short
debate over this but um otherwise we
need to make the decision now so we know
how we proceed for the rest of the
evening
any views
Mike Mike sorry would the future meter
be next week or within two weeks time
they'd be adjourned to a future
committee date as as advertised
okay
that's good I think given the time that
we've taken over the previous
applications I
would prefer that we take the next item
and then the journal I think very long
meetings don't necessarily make for very
good decisions
that's fair how do other members feel
some nods Castle home
I don't know I'm I'm considering you
know the the members of the public that
have come all this way and sat through
this long soccer meeting they don't get
to hear their their item but their their
smts
yeah I know I I do appreciate that
um we need to go one way or the other
um
to keep it form or we need a proposal
and a secondary
I'll propose we do the next one and
defer the final two
thank you just to be clear that's
adjourn them not defer them thank you
and councilor Curtis
um one more Mike's back on I'm happy to
second that okay anyone else want to add
a country view no
in which case uh can I just get a vote
uh adjourn items eight um no sorry seven
and eight to Future meetings
yeah
and all those opposed
okay uh in which case
um item seven and eight will be on
future agendas published in due course
chair yes Council chair if I if I may
could I possibly ask that the Deferred
items come at the front of a planning
meeting not be put at the back
I think that's perfectly reasonable and
um I will also consider talking to
um both planning managers and Community
managers to make sure that the these
things are considered in future I think
we were just
unfortunate by having not enough for the
previous meetings agenda and too many
for this one
um and we'll try to make sure this
doesn't happen again
all right
okay members uh we'll now be a hearing
item six which is application
2300989 out land Northeast of the
exchange Mill Lane Newbold on stower
uh Louise's oh sorry it's not movies
Sarah is a presenting officer and um
please take it away when you're ready
thank you chairman
an outline application for the erection
of five self and custom bow dwellings
with all matters reserved except that
access
application site is denoted by the red
line on this plan and is located outside
of but adjacent to the built-up area
boundary of new build on Star
here we see a satellite view of the site
the site is a paddock which is currently
occupied by a small field shelter seen
here if you can see my cursor
an area proposed with biodiversity
offseting is located directly to the
northeast of the site in this area
a telephone exchange is located directly
to the Southwest seen here
with residential development scene to
the north and east of the site not West
I'm sorry sorry
here we see the proposed site plan
indicating the five plots for the
Southport dwellings
the site will be served by a new access
of Mill Lane the proposed Highway
improvements comprising a passing Bay
and a footway can also partially be seen
on this plan here
this image is taken Facing East and the
application site is located on the right
of this image six meters of the existing
Hedgerow will be removed to facilitate
creation of the new access to the site
here we Face East and into the site the
existing field sheltered to be
demolished can be seen here in the
center of the image with the boundary
with the exchange seen on the right
this final image is taken facing south
west back up Mill Lane towards the a3400
the application size is located behind
the vegetation on the left of the photo
chairman The Proposal complies that with
the development plan is considered to
comply with the development plan taken
as a whole significant weight is
attached to the shortfall in the
provision of self and custom build
housing some limited harm to landscape
has been identified but the principle
principle of development has been found
to be acceptable which is considered to
outweigh this limited harm in the
planning balance it is therefore
officer's recommendation to Grants
subject to a legal agreement and the
conditions as detailed in Pages 97 to 99
of the agenda and the updates in the
update sheet thank you
thank you very much Sarah
um okay we want to move on to our first
Speaker who is councilor Julie Murphy of
treadington Parish Council
good evening councilor you have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning
um it's just the button on the right to
turn the icon perfect and uh you can
start when you're ready thank you thank
you the site of the proposed development
is outside of the built up boundary area
is identified in the transition National
development plan which was ratified this
month the trading term Parish councilor
opposed to supporting sites outside of
the built-up boundary area due to the
impact on the Strategic objective of
as10 and in our opinion this site does
not also comply with core strategies
cs15 and cs16 in addition tradington
Parish Council was able to plan honors
the wishes of the parish for no further
building in the village of Newbold
except reserved sites Newbold has had
extensive building exceeding the number
of houses needed to meet it's in Meet
the indicative proportion of new houses
recommended as a limited service Village
by 13 the proposed development would
would import an urban character an urban
character on the development into what
is otherwise a rule setting this
development would never protect nor
enhance the character of Mill Lane and
its setting the location and extent of
the development in the open Countryside
would cause significant harm to the
Royal rural character of the area and
the rural Integrity of Mill Lane
the application
um the applicant withdrew a previous
application for local needs after it was
clear it was not supported by the
villagers or all tradlington Parish
Council making reference to a housing
needs survey of Jan 2020
um to justify the development this um
questionnaire which went out to 650 40
people was only responded to by 12 which
is a 1.8 response rate we now have this
Open Access
um
application
um that um and it contradicts the um
plan that new Darlene should be direct
directly within the village other than
schemes met by the community needs there
is no specific policy for the
development plans that relates to South
bills and custom builds as we've already
heard tonight this is not a
justification for the approval of this
um
application and we feel that the bulk a
bulk intake by a Newbold itself would to
meet the sdd's South custom bills is
unacceptable given that we already have
13 over subscription of new houses
um we welcome the comments from
councilor Fleming tonight that weight
should be given to a parent
a plan the argument for the Parisian of
South build custom build dwellings in in
open Countryside locations is
outweighted by the significant harm
impacts the proposal would create the
application we feel should be refused as
a parish council
thank you very much well within your
time uh councilors do we have any
questions for our Parish Council
no in which case thank you very much for
your contribution
our next speaker is Andy Clark
good evening Mr Clark
um so yes uh similar procedure you've
got three minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning
um and you can start when you're ready
okay thank you I want to focus on three
areas which is safety sewage and
flooding I'm sure the committee of
visited Mill Lane but just to confirm is
a nearer it's a narrow single track dead
end with an average width of 3.8 meters
vehicles are up and down the lane daily
with Amazon Vans dustman Recycling and
residents family and friends and when
two vehicles want to pass at best they
have to go into the green Verge as
you've seen for yourself but also what
happens more likely is that they do
reverse and sometimes even reverse onto
the A340 Stratford Road it's simply very
dangerous and is a serious accident
waiting to happen
on a sewage size seven Trend are now
coming down Mill Lane monthly fixing
existing problems with the last visit
only two weeks ago in relation to
looking at the sewage challenges we are
facing now I can't go into detail
because I'm not an expert in this area
but we have problems in terms of sewage
now and we have four new large family
houses that are already built and and
empty and they're waiting to stretch to
switch capacity even further surely
we're at our limit now so please
consider chasing up seven trend for a
full report and assessment of sewage
challenges for out Mill Lane before
allowing any more problems literally to
pile up or lashes from flooding I like
to draw the members attention as CS4
within the core strategy where it stays
all proposable take into consideration
the possible impacts of climate change
and minimizing flood rates from all
sources are set out in the sfra in cs4b
it also clearly states no development
will be permitted will result in an
increase in the risk of flooding
elsewhere
therefore could the committee please he
strongly consider that CS4 and cs4b have
been taken into account where Mill Lane
has and continues to suffer from the
impacts of climate change and constant
flooding as per the objection filed with
photos and video evidence by residence
doctors Mike and Stella Khan this
evidence was backed up by the EA in a
letter to his Delta Stella Khan on the
15th of June 2023 when they confirmed
their flood plan for Mill Lane a new
board is significantly down to date and
it is based on data between 2007 and
2010 that's up to 16 years out of date
the existing the EA also confirmed that
they are in receipt of Dr Khan's
evidence of the horrific flooding lay
constantly and neighbors get and
confirmed that they will be revisiting
the flood risk plan for New bold and
will use this and look for information
and use their evidence to help bring
their modeling up to date to close
please reject yourself with application
outright it's been rejected once before
and we know why it's been resubmitted as
a self-build let's do the right thing
and reject it again thank you
thank you very much Mr Clark uh well
within your time members do we have any
questions
thank you chairman thank you very much
Mr Clark uh you mentioned that Vehicles
traveling on Mill Lane couldn't pass
each other because they were so narrow
and I've noticed that the highways have
offered no objection could you tell me
how many properties there are accessing
Mill Lane because I can see another I
can see another road into is it old acre
Gardens do you know roughly how many
properties there are using Mill Lane
you've got access uh Adam well Vehicles
obviously houses houses
itself you've obviously got the six
residents that are already down there
but there's also you've got the new bill
where the Green Acres site was and
they're all a minimum of four or five or
six bedroom houses consider them to be
large family houses they're built
they're up
so roughly how many houses is that okay
there's five new houses that are built
and that so Mill Lane's just serving
five houses it's just serving Prime
houses correct five houses no it's six
eleven but you've got six existing
houses
and then you've got the five new ones
just just on the corner there okay thank
you any further questions
no inch case I believe uh that's
everything thank you very much Miss
Clark
so our
final speakers are Jane Cashmore and
Dave Neal
good evening uh so you've got six
minutes between you
I'll give you a 30 second warning how
would you like to split the time
I'll be taking the speaking time Dave's
just here for any questions on highways
matters yep lovely in which case I'll
give you a 30 second warning uh and feel
free to start when you're ready thank
you good evening
the application is submitted in outline
with all matters reserved except for
Access for five self-built custom build
dwellings which I'll refer to as SCB
firstly thank you to the planning
officer for her comprehensive committee
report
legislation sets out the duty to Grant
planning permission for enough suitable
service plots of land in order to meet
the demand for SCB in the district the
council's Own latest evidence indicates
a substantial shortfall of available
plots for SCB housing
the last sentence of the conclusion on
matters of principle sets out that the
supply of plots does not satisfy the
number of parties on the register so
it's necessary to make available sites
that are suitable to contribute to
meeting that level of demand
neither the core strategy or
neighborhood plan have policies which
address SCB
although the emerging site allocations
plan can only be given limited weight
due to its stage of preparation emerging
sat policy 6 identifies some locations
where SCB will be supported
one of these is on suitable sites
adjacent the buab of local service
villagers
this site does lie adjacent the builds
power boundary of the local service
Village of Newbold as shown in the
neighborhood plan
subject to other detail therefore the
site would comply with these emerging
policy sap6 parameters
legislation and other government
documents provide considerable
expectation and justification for taking
a positive approach to proposals which
deliver SCB
the provision should of self and custom
build properties should therefore carry
significant weight in the planning
balance as your planning officer has
recognized
work on the legal agreement to secure
these five properties is in progress
to secure the properties for yourself
and custom build that is
the objections from the parish council
councilor Harvey and third parties have
been thoroughly addressed in your
officer report
in terms of numbers of housing already
approved in Newbold your officer has
covered this on page 78 of the agenda
there is no evidence that indicates
local infrastructure could not cope with
the proposal
in terms of Highways the application has
been supported by a transport statement
including road safety audit and County
highways have no objection subject
conditions condition 18 recommends a
construction management plan which the
applicant has no objection to
with regards to the landscape impact the
site does not lie in a designated
landscape area and there are no nearby
public rights of way
the recently made neighborhood plan
identifies valued Landscapes and
important Vistas in policy ne3 the site
is not in one of these
a design code accompanies the
application and sets out a number of
parameters that the dwellings would have
to meet
having regard to local characteristics
these parameters amongst other matters
would allow for single or two-story
dwellings but none higher than nine
meters there are minimum separations to
boundaries Landscaping stipulations in
respect to the southeast and Northeast
boundary and the dwellings would face
Mill Lane
the development secures a net
biodiversity gain by off-site provision
which would be secured in the legal
agreement
with regards flooding and drainage your
officer has no objections subject to a
condition regarding climate change as
set out in the report each plot's
Reserve matters would need to come
forward with a climate change checklist
the previous speaker said that this
application has been rejected before it
hasn't as you can see from the site
history table in the report
no objections have been received from
any Technical consulties and I hope
you're able to support the provision of
self and custom build dwellings in the
district and your officer recommendation
to Grant thank you for listening
thank you very much members do we have
any questions
Curtis
thank you
um
can you tell us what the
um rough sale value of these plots will
be
I can't I'm afraid each plot is going to
because it's self and custom build each
one would come forward to that specific
personal families
preferences in terms of size and scale
provided they fit within the design code
and the reserve matters so it may be a
one bed Bungalow it may be a four-story
I'm sorry a four bed two-story family
property so I I couldn't advise on
values
any further questions
no in which case thank you very much
now move on to our final speaker who's
councilor Trevor Harvey
good evening councilor
third time's the challenge Danny
um
thanks very much well you have five
minutes I'll um restrain from giving you
a 30 second warning and take it away
when you're ready
thank you Mr chairman this application
has only one redeeming feature and that
it's because it's a five a proposal for
five self-built dwellings but for this
the application would already have been
refused by the case officer because it
doesn't comply with the principle of
development in this location it fails to
comply with the either the core strategy
notably CS 15 and 16 and as10 or with
the newly made tradington NDP
regardless of that other speakers have
drawn attention to a number of other
ways in which this application give rise
gives rise to objections
I'd like to draw the committee's
attention to three recent decisions to
dismiss appeals that involved
applications for self-build dwellings by
different planning inspectors
the first is a decision made in April
this year this involved a proposal to
build four such dwellings on land off
the Ulster Road in Studley
the proposed site was also as in this
case outside the relevant buab and in
that instance was washed over by the
green belt
despite the council's obligations under
the self-build and custom house building
act 2015 the inspector dismissed this
appeal demonstrating that just because
an application is for self-built houses
and despite the council's obligation
under the 2015 act this does not mean
that the self-build obligation trumps
all other planning considerations
applications for self-built houses can
justifiably be refused
the second inspector's decision to
dismiss an appeal was delivered just two
weeks ago this was for one self-built
house in tiddington Road in Stratford
again despite the of the council's
obligations under the 2015 act the
inspector dismissed the appeal tellingly
the inspector wrote quote even so the
proposal would add only one additional
dwelling to the supply of self-built
accommodation as such its contribution
to the supply and its wider benefits
would be limited I therefore give these
benefits only moderate weight
the third appeal was dismissed in May
2023 the inspector concern dismissed two
related appeals for a total of six
self-build dwellings at earlswood common
in that instance the inspector
considered amongst other matters whether
the proposed developments were
appropriate development in the green
belt
but this decision is of even greater
significance in paragraph 35 of his
decision inspector David Jones sites
cs-16 as his authority for pointing out
that in the category 3 limited service
Village which Newbold is
no more than 13 should be provided in
any individual settlement
in the case of such a village inspector
Jones stated that this equates to 58
dwellings per settlement he goes on to
make the seminal statement that quote it
should be noted however that this is a
maximum figure
given that Newbold has already had
approval for 106 dwellings it's already
met 23 and a half percent rather than 13
of its housing requirement a decision to
Grant this application would therefore
be completely to ignore inspector
Jones's decision and could arguably put
the council at some risk the over
provision in Newbold has already been
recognized in the emerging sap because
no further Reserve sites are proposed
for Newbold to conclude Mr chairman this
application has only one redeeming
feature it's a proposal for self-build
dwellings in the open Countryside
the inspector's decisions to which I've
drawn attention collectively demonstrate
that the council's obligation under the
2015 act do not override all other
considerations that all relevant
material considerations need to be
weighed in the planning balance and that
the self-built basis of similar size
schemes to this application have only
been allocated moderate weight
issues concerning the implications for
Access and road safety the consequences
of rainwater runoff the constraints on
the currents in sewage installation have
all been raised and Merit weighing in
the planning belts most specifically on
the basis of Inspector Jones's words new
world has significantly exceeded its
maximum obligation under cs-16 in
contributing to the council's policy of
balanced distribution under cs-15 there
are sound planning reasons there for the
committee on balance to refuse this
application in my view it should be
refused
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our Ward member
oh councilor Parry just got it
just if you wouldn't mind
being very succinct as you normally do
can you explain how this site
does not then conform to the self-build
and custom building Act
in your view
sorry it doesn't conform because there
is no need for these houses because
there's over prison provision already
within Newbold whether it's self-build
or any other build
the numbers are already there
based upon one inspector I agree it's
one inspector and we can debate what
on uh what what the precise terms of Cs
16 mean but this particular inspector is
has a first degree a master in planning
and he's a chartered planner he's not a
stupid man
thank you very much any other questions
for our member
no in which case councilor Harvey thank
you very much
all right we'll now move on to points of
clarification from our officers I'm
going to start
counselor Harvey alluded to three
appeal decisions which seem to
contradict
um the the assessment that you've made
could you confirm their relevance how
much they've been taken into account
for this application please
I I can touch on two of the appeal
decisions because they were my
applications
um D1 councilor Harvey refers to in
Studley was a permission and principal
application for four dwellings and it
was in the green belt so with quite a
different policy context I would say and
the one in Erza common was also in the
green belt so again a different
different policy context there the
tiddington road application I'd have to
defer to David for a comment on that one
yeah the tiddington road application was
an application to the rear of an
existing dwelling on tiddington road and
there were other issues relating to um
the danger of being struck by golf balls
um the the inspector in that appeal was
concerned that there wasn't a mechanism
in place to secure this particularly as
a self-build and in any case as he
referred to it only as a single
self-built dwelling it made a very
modest contribution to any apparent
shortfall so he
um he gave that very little weight in
his overall planning balance
I think the key one that uh councilor
Harvey talked about was the case at
earlswood common
um that was in the green belt as Sarah
mentioned so it was quite a different
planning context
um context
um the wording of cs16 for the local
service Village those local service
Village allocation is no more than
around
um and I think that was inserted by an
inspector who was overseeing the
adoption of the core strategy in 2016.
um the inspector on that appeal has
interpreted it as a maximum and in my
view he's done so because it contains
the words no more however the word
around is also in there and that means
it's not a precise maximum
um and therefore it needs to be seen in
the context of CX cs16
um as we've already touched on and
there's reported in our agenda so cs16
and other other policies in the core
strategy need to be weighed and
considered in the context of the self
and custom-built Housing Act which post
dates them and we should afford weight
to those policies accordingly we think
that they are Merit moderate weight in
that context
um and we've weighed that and we think
that it's outweighed by the benefit of
self-built custom housing in this case
thank you very much do we have any
further
Parry I'm sorry
um David I just could do with
um some clarification councilor Harvey
made specific reference to an appeal in
new bold in New boulden Star
no
I thought he he was he he did make some
specific reference to an appeal land off
Ulster Road studly tiddington Road
Stratford and six dwelling settles would
common
if you've got a point of clarification
where
thank you uh councilor Curtis
thank you I'm giving some of the
concerns raised around sewage should we
be concerned that
um there's been no consultation received
from Seven Trent
I would say anecdotally it's not
uncommon that we don't receive a
response to consultation with them but I
would point you in the direction of
condition
sorry let me just get there
um
we've got conditions 11 and 12 which
pertain to drainage and these
applications will be sent out for
consultation with both seven Trend and
building control
for drainage matters for the plots
are rather disturbing that we don't get
consultation back from 710 particularly
given their current
I'm not saying no responses but yeah no
noted uh councilor Keith do you think
thank you chair
um this is a question of clarification
for me in respect of policy H1 in the
neighborhood development plan and on
page 96 you comment that the
neighborhood development plan can only
be given moderate weight because it does
not address the provision for
um self-built self and custom-built
housing
um
could you explain why a neighborhood
development plan that has just been made
fails to address the requirement of the
district to find self and customer
housing plots
I think it's fair to say that
neighborhood plans in the district are
produced by parish councils and their
constituents and they cover the matters
which they feel are most pertinent they
are not driven by legislation or the
nppf to the same degree that perhaps a
new local plan would be so they as I say
they they tackle those issues which are
most relevant to them
in this case they're cover self and
custom-built housing
Council Parry
yes if I could just have some further
clarification the proposed site
um
I understood from the officer was not a
reserve site whereas conversely in the
previous self-build application that was
a site that was featured in that was
included in the site allocations plan so
we have quite a differential
um so this site is is not a reserve site
there's not in not does not feature in
the site allocations plan so therefore
what weight
can we
um
gift to that because there is there is a
differential in terms of these two sites
that we've been just discussing this
evening yeah I think your summary is
correct that this is not a site that's
identified specifically in the site
allocations plan which is emerging
whereas the previous application for
self-build on this agenda was that way
in favor of the previous application I
think the fact that this isn't
identified in the site allocations plan
doesn't weigh against this proposal
um it is just a matter of fact that it
is not part of that emerging document at
the current time
for whatever reason
oh no
any further points of clarification
no in which case we can move to the
debate let's start
counselor Perry I couldn't tell if
you're putting your hand it's unfair I
think I think I'm very happy for my
fellow colleagues
um
I think this is quite an interesting
application and it does differ
from the previous application that we've
had this evening and I think it is of
Merit the fact that it is not a not on a
site that is already included in the
site allocations plan it is not on a
site that the
um tredington
neighborhood development plan which has
been made in the last
two weeks
and therefore we we actually that we
have a differential here I think the
fact that the previous
self-build application was on a site
included in the site allocations plan
um
has more weight towards it and therefore
I think particularly with the fact that
Newbold has more than delivered its
housing Supply and this is not
on a reserve site
I think we have material planning
reasons to refuse
and I'm happy to propose that
thank you councilor Parry Council head
and
yeah
um
I 100 agree with you councilor Parry um
I do give some weight to it not being a
reserve site I do believe that the
policy H1
is later than the self-build policies
and it says no building outside the
built up area boundary and then further
backed by some of our older policies
which are obviously being outweighed so
for me I think we do have material
um considerations here and I will second
councilor Perry's proposal
thank you very much uh who would like to
speak Nets councilor Keithley I'm
finding this a bit tricky because I
thought I heard when we asked the
officer about the site allegations plan
that he said that the fact that it was
not in the site allocations plan did not
weigh against this application
however I'm
um
color leaning towards the fact that
you've got policy H1 and this
neighborhood development plan has just
been written and this is a site outside
the Builder barrier boundary so
um at the moment I'm turning to over in
my mind
at this point I would
suggest that we we just take stock of
the fact that it is the application in
front of us that we are looking at I
appreciate that we have seen a very
similar application this evening
and that there are similarities and
differences which can be marked and will
be present in our minds but we have to
be very conscientious when it comes to
speaking about exactly what is in front
of us this evening and what's within the
officers report
we don't like to speak
next no
um
I will add I
I'm slightly concerned I
agree very much with the sentiment
that's been expressed I have a slight
concern that
the lack of a positive support through
an inclusion in a sap
is being seen as a negative against the
application
that is not the case
that being said it is adjusting the
balance as we are seeing it as of
committee
that's my reading of it I think that's
Fair
I am itching to find the good planning
reasons
to go against this
for the
on the basis of effectively the
precedent in May set but also for the
local
um local community I feel that one thing
that's stuck in my mind is that the most
recent piece of legislation that's been
put forward albeit local was the NDP
on that basis I'm certainly
in spirit behind this app
application being refused
I think we have to be absolutely clear
though that that will be suitable
um in terms of the risk that it does
still pose to the council in terms of an
appeal because these do come to appeal
and we have to be aware of that
right that's more of a statement than a
point in debate
um I'm just gonna consult with our
planning manager to make sure that he's
got what he needs and then we'll look at
moving it forwards
so I just want some clarification from
councilor Parry as the proposer
um
in terms of the reasons for refusal
you are using the NDP being the most
recent piece of legislation passed not
identifying this site or some or being
happy with sites outside the building
today the cheddington neighborhood plan
was
um made and agreed at full Council on
the 10th of July
and that has been through the policy
team at SDC has its full approval and
weight and therefore it's policy H1 it
is very current and recent
I also still do believe the fact that
this particular site therefore is not in
the NDP and it's not in any other site
allocations plan within SDC and that
must therefore carry
cumulatively significant weight
against this application
thank you
um I'm satisfied then that we take it to
the vote on that proposal
okay
thank you
so the proposal is to refuse the
application
um with conditions and wording delegate
with
sorry yes sorry
that we refuse permission with reasons
for refusal delegated to officers
uh in line with what members have said
can I see all those in favor
in which case committee resolves to
refuse application
2300989 o u t
right
uh
further to our vote earlier to adjourn
items seven and eight to a future
meeting uh we'll just move on to item 10
urgent business
no